CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Thanks.
Thank you.
So my kind of
usual data shtick I
think is probably going
to be wasted on you guys,
because you probably
know the basics for sure.
So I'm just going to
run through some data
that we used especially in
the formative days of OkCupid
to make the site better or the
sort of things that eventually
gave rise to the
blog and to the book.
And then I will answer
questions if there are any,
just because I've found
for audiences like this
I'm a bad predictor
of what people
want to talk about
or hear about.
So I'm happy to answer anything.
There, so, I am one of
four founders of OkCupid.
I still run the
business day to day.
And we started the
site back in 2003.
We had actually all
quit SparkNotes,
which was on the ninth
floor of this building.
I remember we were in
there before September 11
and then after, so I used to
be able to just walk in, take
the elevator up, and go to work.
So I had the whole kind
of Homeland Security style
process getting here today.
And so we started
the site in 2003
basically as an answer
to the eHarmony,
highly prescriptive
soulmate-oriented dating model.
And I'm not sure exactly how
they run their site these days,
but it used to be
this thing where
you answer this really
long questionnaire.
Certain answers could
totally disqualify you.
And then in addition, after
you went through that,
they would show you this
very curated but almost
highly restricted
list of people you
could talk to that they
thought were perfect for you.
And then if you
didn't like them,
you got three or
five matches a day,
and then it was like, too bad.
We'll see you
tomorrow, hopefully.
So the reaction to
that from us was,
we want to just make it
kind of open where people
could find whatever they wanted.
And of course, as you
guys know, as soon
as you start asking questions
like what users want,
what do users want, or how
can this person do something
on the site, you have to
start collecting data.
And the way we did that was
these match questions, which
just ask kind of
everything under the sun.
It's about religion, and flag
burning, and abortion, and then
about scary movies, and
brushing your teeth,
and all kinds of nonsense also.
And then we basically-- my
co-founder Chris Coyne did it--
but together we kind
of refined this idea
of what it means for two
people to sort of get
to know each other, which
was our intent for the site.
It's just asking a series
of questions like banter
and how much your answers
satisfy each other.
And it's pretty simple, and
we put it into a formula,
and it gives out a
percentage even to this day,
although there's been
some slight tweaks
and we don't always use
that exact formula anymore
or algorithm.
But so one of the things about
a dating site that is unique
is that you're trying
to connect people
with people rather than
people with content or people
with search results that they
want or people with cool things
to pin or whatever.
So there's a lot of
kind of bizarre things
or special things
about a dating site.
So we started this thing
and matching people up,
and we learned very quickly
that you can have an algorithm,
and you can return 10 of
the say 10,000 people at
that point that you have
in New York for this person
to look at.
And regardless of whether the
viewer is a man or a woman,
and regardless of
what the numbers are
that your algorithm has
output alongside each picture,
and even regardless of
the various biographical
details attached
to each picture,
they just click on
the hottest picture.
So it's what we have come
to call the focus problem.
For this reason,
men and women focus
on the most attractive
person on the page.
And so in aggregate,
these attractive people
just get targeted, just bombed.
And they get way
too many messages.
They get grossed out.
It's almost always a
woman in this situation.
They get grossed out.
They don't answer them.
They leave.
Guys don't get replies.
They leave, and it's just
a huge kind of implosion.
And so I guess this
is a good time to ask,
is this slide thing
actually working?
Because it's not-- there it is.
This is my first slide.
It was hard.
So we realized really
quickly that we
needed to solve this
problem, and of course you
could impute how-- you need
to know how hot people are
so you can manage
the experience.
And you could impute
hotness, obviously,
by who gets the most messages.
That's almost like that would
be the best way to do it.
Except that you have to have
the problem occur that you're
trying to prevent in
order to prevent it.
It doesn't really work.
So we need to be
able to figure out
how hot people are before
they get too many messages.
And so the way you do that
is you just let people rate.
It's very low friction.
They just volunteer this
information very quickly.
We called it Quickmatch.
It's basically a
knockoff of Hot or Not,
which has kind of resurrected
itself as a knockoff itself
of Tinder, but way
back in the day
was just this thing where you
rate one to 10 stars for people
over and over again.
And that's what we did.
And we launched it, and we
were getting the information,
and we were managing the
experience or whatever.
But obviously you
pilot histograms
of how people are
rating things and just
to see what's going on.
And this is the-- I'll
use this one-- this
is the histogram of female
looks, straight female looks,
on OkCupid.
So this is women
rated by guys and how
the population sorts itself out.
As you can see, it's
actually on a one to five
scale it's centered
almost at three.
I think the median here is
2.83, which is very healthy.
This reflects, I think,
the intuitive idea
of what attractiveness is in
the external world, right?
You have some people
that are very ugly,
some people that are very
hot, and then most people
are just in the middle
somewhere, right?
And so this is a sign
that you have devised
your metric or your
interface pretty well,
and we are happy about that.
And it also is an odd thing.
It's-- well, never mind.
Well, I was going
to say-- thanks.
So there's this
idea that I think
is true in a lot of situations
that Photoshop, or retouching
in other ways, or just
models in general,
magazine covers, have kind
of reformulated the idea
or have reformulated
the idea about what
it is to be beautiful.
And you would imagine
that in a situation
where men expect every woman to
be a supermodel, to put it very
bluntly, that this
curve would be way down.
They would think that
the average woman
that they see, they would
be shifted way further
down towards ugly because
they expect everyone
to be, whatever-- thin, tall,
beautiful, blonde, who knows.
So this is actually
kind of-- the normalness
of this curve is in its
normality sort of refreshing.
It means that
people haven't taken
that kind of marketing
image of attraction to heart
quite as much.
And this is how women rate guys.
It's definitely a
harsher reality.
And in fact, the median there
is like 2.06 or something
like this, which is
actually a little bit
deceptive because the
scale starts at one,
so really this is like
half, basically, as hot.
And obviously the first
reaction is all the dudes
on OkCupid are ugly,
which is a problem.
But we tested it.
We pulled 1,000 random
guys off a social network
and put it against
1,000 of our own dudes,
and the scores came out
almost exactly the same.
So I don't think that that's
actually what's going on.
And obviously women
are more selective,
and that's how this works.
And an interesting
perspective on this,
I gained an interesting
perspective on this
when I presented the
slide right after.
A guy who was a behavioral
psychologist, and right
before this he had
explained this experiment
that they had run,
him and his team,
a very kind of classic sort
of academic social research.
They got a hot
woman and a hot guy
to run out into the campus quad,
or walk, and go talk to people.
And the experiment
ran in three phases.
First phase is they'd go out.
The hot woman or guy
approaches somebody,
and the end of the
conversation is, hey,
do you want to go on a date?
That's the proposition.
And the attractive woman
and the attractive guy
got just about the same number
of yeses from their marks,
so to speak.
I think it was something
around 85%, 80%.
Second phase, they go out.
They find people to chat
up, and then the proposition
there is, hey, do you
want to go home with me?
And the woman talking
to the men out there
got basically the
same number of yeses
as she got asking
them on a date.
They're like, yeah,
I thought that's what
we were talking about.
And the guy, of course, when
he goes out there and accosts
women out of nowhere
and then winds up with,
hey, do you want
to go home with me,
got very, very, very few yeses.
I think it was
something like 5%.
So there you see
a huge disparity
in the approval rating
of that kind of question.
And then finally, I don't
know how they did this
with a straight face, but
they ran the same thing again,
and the man went out there,
and at the end he's like, hey,
do you want to go
have sex with me?
And he got zero
yeses from women.
The woman goes out
and does this and gets
something like 70%
yeses from guys.
There were only a few.
Because again they're
just like, right,
I mean, that's why you're
talking to me, isn't it?
OkCupid was bought
by IAC in 2011.
They also own match.com.
They also own Tinder.
And you see this kind
of spectrum of judgment
I guess playing out
in these data sets.
So the proposition on match.com
is much more like, hey,
do you want to go on a date?
That's sort of
the implicit thing
behind what's going
on on that site.
On match.com, the blue and
red curves almost overlap.
So men and women sort of
say yes to one another
basically in the same ratio.
Tinder, where it's
a lot more casual,
you see the blue histogram is
slammed way against the y-axis.
That first bar is
the tallest one.
And OkCupid is
somewhere in the middle.
Some people use it
for casual hook-ups.
Some people use it for
long-term relationships,
and you have a kind
of a compromise.
And I just saw,
especially because there's
three and three,
I saw an analogy
in what this man had
been talking about.
This is always good.
So anyway, so it's this is
kind of data that we use.
Not necessarily the histogram
because there's not a lot
we can do about
the general trend
of how men and women perceive
each other on OkCupid.
But we take the results
of your star rating
and kind of manage
the experience for you
if you do a search.
We always add
randomness, because I
think fundamentally
everyone knows and we also
believe that there's a lot
of serendipity and randomness
in love.
But we kind of collar it.
If you're a six out
of 10, your matches
will tend to be like four
to seven, four to eight.
So anytime someone
complains to you
that all the people
on OkCupid are ugly,
you can kind of
smile to yourself
about what that implies.
So, we also use this
data in other ways,
mostly because it's such a
low-friction way for people
to volunteer their
opinions of strangers.
It helps us understand what's
going on with the business.
And another important axis
besides gender is age.
And so this is
using the same data,
but it's obviously
sliced a lot differently.
I'll explain it
over here this time.
So the age-- this is
women voting on men.
So the age of the
women is on the y-axis,
which probably
should be reversed.
And then the age of
the men is on the x.
And so the way to look
at this, and the numbers
are not exactly deciles.
They're rounding of percentiles.
But this is the sort of
spine, the hottest cohort
as rated by the women going up.
So you see 20-year-old
women think
23-year-old guys are hottest.
25-year-old women think
26-year-old guys are hottest.
30 think 30.
35, 34 I think.
But basically it's a
diagonal more or less,
meaning that women think
guys who are their same age
are the best looking.
And they want a guy to be their
same age until-- women after 40
are totally cool if the
dude is not over 40.
They kind of stop.
A guy is sort of over the
hill at, say, 39 or 40.
A 45-year-old for
the most part would
prefer a 39 or 40-year-old.
You can just see
the color is meant
to add some kind of
topography to this thing.
And you can see it's kind
of like, well, it's a spine.
It's well distributed.
It's a little hill, ridge
running through the thing.
And this is it
going the other way.
So guys basically
universally thinks
that basically 20,
21, 22-year-old women
are the hottest.
Of course that fits our own.
You don't see that many
40-year-old women on magazine
covers, at least as
objects of lust, for sure.
And that's this
played out right here.
Of course, again, this is
a very low-friction way
to collect this information.
The guy does not have
to put himself out there
to contribute this.
You're just sitting there
voting yes, no, or whatever.
And I use the gestural thing
because we ripped that off
from Tinder about a year ago.
But where you do have
to put yourself out
there is sending a message and
actually hitting on somebody
or whatever it is,
chatting them up.
And there you see there's pride.
There's fear of rejection.
There's also taboo.
I mean, it has got to
feel weird being 45
and trying to chat up somebody
who's still in college.
It sounds insane to me.
So you see people compromise.
They compromise between
pride and lust, as it were.
It kind of runs a slope
of maybe two or something.
So guys message women about 10
to 15 years younger than they
are as far as where most of
the messages actually go.
And so this is an
example of information
that we don't actually act on.
Again, getting back to
what I started with,
we always want
OkCupid to be open.
And a very easy way to solve
the creepiness problem here
is just make it impossible
for-- I don't know--
for 40-year-old guys to even
see 20-year-old profiles,
certainly to message them.
Obviously you just display
equals none on the button.
But we don't do that
just because we kind of
try never to bar anybody from
doing anything on OkCupid,
although we do consider
it from time to time.
But the actual
volume of messages
that goes in this older
man to younger woman
is relatively low.
Oh yeah, and one
other thing I guess
I want to point out about this.
And this is something I
haven't exactly figured out
is there's this
sort of hill here,
which is the kind of
youngish dudes thinking
they're inverse cougars
or hikers, whatever
you want to call them.
They're waiting to
get snatched up, which
is kind of a funny point.
Somebody asked
earlier-- actually it
might have been at
Google when I talked out
there a couple weeks
ago-- whether this
was just a weird thing
that's going to float on up,
a cohort thing that's just going
to be the case for these guys
through their lives.
But of course longitudinal
data is kind of
hard to come by,
especially in dating,
because we have this sort of--
unlike many of the services
you guys offer, or Facebook.
For example, Google Maps,
or certainly Google Search,
or Facebook totally works
great for you whether you're 18
or you're 25 or you're
40 or you're 60.
It's like, people need
dating in a very acute way,
but not for very long, because
both in the success and failure
case for our site,
people leave it,
which is kind of a weird
thing to think about.
So we definitely get very,
very little actual cohort
longitudinal data on what
the hell is going on.
And then I guess
the last question
I want to talk about,
how as you guys know,
you measure what's
happening on your site,
and you take some action based
on it that is either obvious
or that your intuition
hopes that will work out.
And you run some sort of test.
And there's obviously on an
issue of pricing, for example,
you're just going to look
at total revenue or revenue
expectation or whatever, LTV.
It's pretty easy to know
what the metric is there.
But for us-- and
this is something
that took a while
in evolving-- is
how do you know when
you make a change based
on any of this data whether
it's actually good for the site
or not?
Because something like
retention-- or sorry, well,
retention, the
classic engagement,
time on site, even
page views are
sort of crappy markers
for how well you're doing.
Because if people have spent
seven years on OkCupid,
unless they're using it
to go on casual dates,
you've really screwed up, right?
You've failed, essentially.
And so it took us a
while to realize this.
So then you could
go, well, all right,
what we really want to
do is have conversations.
Because we don't know who
actually goes on dates.
There's this huge wall
where we know everything,
and then we know nothing.
It's like this shroud
of ignorance for us.
And so we have to
make a guess as
to what's contributing
towards people going on dates.
And so obviously messages
has got to be a precursor.
People can't possibly
get together.
There's no smoke signals.
People have to send
each other messages.
Of course you end up with an
extreme power user problem
there too, because
there will be guys
who send 1,000 messages,
basically the same.
And so the pure volume
isn't a good one,
so obviously the next step there
is reply rate because that's
some indication of quality
and the female satisfaction
with the messages
they're getting.
And I'm using male to
female because that's
how 80-plus percent
of the messages
are for first
contacts on the site.
And we were using
that for a long time
as our sort of metric for any
A/B test involving the UX.
But there's too many
false positives.
There's too many polite
replies of people
being like, not
interested or buzz off.
So a reply is a
one and then a two,
so then we did one, two, three.
So the reply has
to be good enough
to elicit a further
message from a guy.
But again, then we
recently upped it four.
So me, you, me, you,
that's our success case.
Because even in the three way,
if a woman writes a guy buzz
off, there were just too many
false positives of the guy
being like, well, buzz off too.
So, I mean, you all know
how the internet is.
So now we use four ways.
Obviously we could
take it out to n.
You're definitely more
certain that people
are having a productive
conversation or at least
a substantial conversation
the longer you take that out.
But at a certain point, you
start having a false negatives
problem where people
exchange, yeah, sounds great.
I live in Brooklyn.
Here's my phone number.
And you start losing that.
So four is kind of an intuitive
guess at what seems best.
That's an irony of
what we're doing
is that we can't tell
who actually goes
on dates except in extreme cases
of people coming back to us way
after they've started
dating long term
and telling us
that that happened.
Like, hey, my name is Alice,
and I met Bob on your site.
Thank you, that kind of
thing, which is obviously
a highly self-selected
and rare thing.
So basically in
doing this work, you
can see we're
dealing with people
and personal interactions and
strangers judging strangers.
And so you kind of
start learning a lot
just about human nature broadly.
And we started writing about
that stuff on the blog in 2009.
And it occurred to me after
I had exhausted both might
by patience and ideas
with what OkCupid
was doing that people at
places like Facebook or Google
obviously are learning
similar things.
And so the reason
I wrote the book
is to kind of tie all this
stuff that's out there together.
I mess around a
little bit on my own
with Google Trends and Ngrams.
There's a guy, Seth
Stephens-Davidowitz.
I don't know if
you all know him.
He works at Google out
in California, I believe,
and he's published a lot
of really amazing op-eds
in the "Times"
using search data,
aggregated and
anonymized, of course.
So I bring in some of
what he's been working on.
And Facebook's
data team has been
doing a lot of
social scholarship.
And basically that's the book.
It tries to give
a picture of how
data is being used to
understand human nature rather
than the dollars and cents side.
And that is where I'm
going to open it up
to questions, if there are any.
Yeah, rare, all right.
Oh, please.
AUDIENCE: You talked about
finding out how hot people are
and then showing them people
who are in the same category.
So two questions tied to that.
One is, do you still
use the ratings
for that, because that
seems like there's
a lot of other things besides
physical attractiveness
that might go into that.
There's other things
that you could
use, like click-through
rates where you're only
seeing a photo, that might
be more directly tied
to how hot people are.
And the second piece is,
in using that in something
like Special Blend, is that
the only thing you use?
You take that and
then randomize it,
or are there other things that
go into choosing how to group
the people that you show?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: I'll answer
your questions in reverse.
Special Blend I'm actually
not exactly sure everything
that goes into there.
I know there's some jitter.
There's attractiveness.
There's match percentage.
There might be some kind
of zip code-based thing.
I honestly don't know
exactly what goes into there.
Basically the
question you're asking
is, do we believe
Quickmatch actually reflects
people's physical attractiveness
rather than this more
abstract idea about
how cool they are
or attractive they are
in a more general way?
And the answer to that is, we
have run a test where we just
have the picture, and
then we have the picture
plus the stuff around
it in Quickmatch.
And on a per capita
level, the correlation
between the two ratings is
something like 92% or 0.92.
So it's like your picture
is almost the entire story.
Granted it is not
the entire story,
but we definitely
use it as a shortcut
to this, especially because if
we took all that stuff away,
people would want that, and
we would have to go then
create this other
engine to gather
the same, slightly better data.
And now you have-- I mean,
you know how UXs can be.
You can't have two
things that are almost
the same but
different, and then you
have a problem on
your hands just
from a User Experience
perspective.
Go ahead, or are you
just standing guard?
AUDIENCE: No, I have a
question, but let him go first.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, one of the
interesting OkCupid blog
entries was pulled.
This is the one that was heavily
researched about, OK, this
is why free dating sites are
better than pay dating sites.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: And it seemed very
well researched and analyzed,
and I couldn't immediately
see anything wrong with it.
And it was pulled, and
then later you came back
and said, well, now that we've
seen the insides of things
after being bought
by IAC, things
are different but never really
addressed what's different.
What were you wrong
with in the first place.
How do you respond to
yourself and that post
that you pulled down?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Sure.
So the genuine truth
is we pulled down
the post of our own volition
because they bought us,
and it was a big middle
finger to match.com.
And these are people that
we have to work with,
and why preserve that?
Why begin a relationship where
you have to work with them
with that on the table, right?
So it's an etiquette matter.
And then over the course
of working with them,
the subtext of that post
was that they basically
don't really care about
getting you a match,
or the site doesn't
work for that.
And I can certainly say I
have learned, for instance,
we have kind of co-opted
part of their matching
algorithm on our site.
We go on match questions.
They use this kind of
interesting I guest network
completion sort of thing that
doesn't use any interests.
It basically looks at if you
and I have a good conversation,
then it's trying to
figure out the next person
to recommend to me.
It looks at the other guys
you've had good conversations
with, and presuming that they're
similar to me in some way,
then what women have they
had good conversations with?
So that kind of extra step out,
and then matches me with them.
And we were using data
from press releases
and whatever publicly
available stuff we could have.
And you guys can imagine
that that stuff can
be distorted if you're
a motivated person.
I was a motivated
person, obviously,
working from the outside.
So my opinion of what they
do and how that site works
has definitely changed.
We've learned a lot about
how to make money off
of running a dating
site from them.
I mean, I work at OkCupid.
I think it's better,
but I don't think
paying for dating, obviously,
is not categorically a bad way
to go about it.
I don't know.
That's pretty much
my honest answer.
My opinion of the
situation has changed.
I have way better information.
And we took it down, and
it will always remain down
just because there's just
no point to having that out
there when you're trying to
have a productive relationship
with people.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Oh, sorry man.
You sent me over
here, and I'm stuck.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's my fault.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
I'll go over here.
Let's do this fairly.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Sorry about that.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
Yeah, it's no problem.
AUDIENCE: I just had a
question about the early days
of OkCupid.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: How did you
get your first users?
How did you achieve
the critical mass
you needed to get
things rolling?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
Right, and to be
clear, OkCupid was a very
linear type of story.
It was not one of these hockey
stick exponential situations.
We were just kind of cruising
along in a user growth way,
but revenue-wise we were
about to go out of business
in 2009, even that late.
So part of it was a
cheat, essentially.
My other three
partners had started
SparkNotes, and I was
an employee there.
And so we advertised.
We were able to advertise
on SparkNotes and say, hey,
this is our next thing.
And that obviously has
some kind of cachet.
So we got an early core
of users, not many,
but some small
five-digit number,
if I remember, sort
of right off the bat.
And you know it's so
much easier to start
from that than from 10.
So that helped.
We basically tried everything.
We've never marketed,
so we tried--
SparkNotes' success
was created basically
by online tests and
silly viral content,
so we tried OkCupid's
version of that.
We had it so people could
generate their own tests.
And this is back when blogs
were still kind of a thing,
or personal blogs
were kind of emerging.
And people would print their
test results or be like, ha ha.
And instead of posting
it to Facebook,
which didn't exist
at that time, they
would post it on their blog,
which really helped with SEO.
So when people searched
dating site or whatever,
they found OkCupid.
We were one of the only free
legit free sites back then too.
So there was a price
proposition there.
And, look, there's a lot of luck
involved in anything like this.
I mean, I think
anybody who pretends
that they've started a
company and it's successful
and luck had nothing to
do with it is a madman.
So we kind of sweated it out.
The general stigma
around online dating
eroded partially because
of what we were doing,
but just partially honesty
because of Facebook.
People started to
realize their friendships
and social lives in some
degree ran through, well,
not their phone then,
but the computer.
And that made the
leap to, OK, well,
I'm already living
part of my life here.
I'm going to live
other part of my life
through a computer made
it a lot less weird,
and that helped a lot.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, the male-female
graph for straight people
is really interesting.
Have you ever done the same
thing for gay men and lesbians?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: I have.
I definitely have done it, and I
just cannot remember the trend.
Someone asked me
this, and I know
that that's a really
shitty answer.
But I have.
My experience with this
stuff is that generally guys
act like guys regardless
of whether they're
straight or gay.
And women act like
women, so I'm going
to guess that the two things
are very, very similar.
My email is christian@okcupid.
I can confirm that for
you when I get back
to my actual desktop.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it's the
person doing the rating.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If I had to bet on it, I would
say that that's what goes on.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
thanks for coming in.
And-- oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: No, you're good.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
This is good exercise.
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah,
thanks for the talk.
So, you mentioned in
the earlier question
that for a dating
site to make money,
you need people to
stay on your site.
So either immediate success
or long-term failure
is not good for you.
So how do you balance that?
You want people on your
site to make money,
but people won't stay
on your site forever.
You know that.
So--
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Yeah,
I mean, here's the thing.
I don't know if it's true that
people staying on the site
actually helps.
I mean, it makes you
incrementally more money
in a certainly very narrow way.
You show more ads
or whatever it is.
AUDIENCE: OkCupid
is free, right?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
There's a freemium thing.
So basically the site
as it was created,
that entire functionality
remains free,
and we've kind of
layered on extra things
that people can pay for if
they want a kind of easier
or get rid of the ads, whatever.
So here's the answer
to the question.
It's like, I guess the site
may make more money by doing
these kind of
Farmville-style tricks
to kind of keep people in.
They're just churning.
But also this is
where the fact that we
don't spend on
marketing comes in.
And we would not
continue to grow
if we do that,
because the only way
we get a new user
is by word of mouth.
And if people feel like
they're kind of being gamed,
everybody has that
feeling, or they
feel like it's kind
of shitty, but they
can't get away from it.
They're not going to
tell their friend.
And more to the point, we
need people to actually go
on the dates so that their
roommate is like, oh,
where did you meet
her, or whatever.
The weddings happen, and
hey, where did they meet?
And the answer is OkCupid.
That's how people
come to the site.
That's the best possible word
of mouth you could have is
where a couple gets
married because of OkCupid,
and all 300 people
know that it works,
and it worked really
well, and it's safe,
and all of this stuff.
So it's part of our user
acquisition strategy, I guess.
It's a little bit intention
with our monetization strategy.
But we prioritize we got to
have people come through.
It's a precursor
for making money.
So we really sincerely do
try to get people on dates
and off the site as
quickly as we can.
AUDIENCE: So, a
follow-up question
to that, so, some
of the dating sites
might allege that they are
better because they just
have to sign up you
pay $50 or something.
So in that case,
they might allege
that OkCupid is
wants to keep you
on the site versus their site
is better for the end goal.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: They
might allege that, yeah.
I'm sure you guys are all
familiar with allegations that
can be thrown at various
internet companies.
What can I say?
It's not true.
I would find it hard to counter
the argument that I just
made that it is in our interest
to kind of keep people trapped
and unhappy on OkCupid, if you
believe that because they're
trapped they're unhappy, which
I think people are savvy enough
at this point to not-- I
mean, for the exact reason
that Farmville and Zynga
generally is having trouble.
And that kind of the
latest-- I don't even
remember the word-- but the
iPhone games that are popular,
and then they get you
to pay for things.
There's some word for
those I can't remember.
In a payment style
thing, there's
so much churn at
the top of the list.
Whereas we could do that.
We could be number one for a
while, and then we'd be gone.
So that's my two
cents on that answer.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
thanks for coming in.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: My pleasure.
AUDIENCE: And thanks
for creating the site.
My little brother is
getting married in December.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
There you go, man.
AUDIENCE: Met on OkCupid.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Right on cue.
AUDIENCE: So it works.
One question I had for
you was I saw the OkTrends
article that you had where
when people match and close
their accounts, they say,
oh who'd you match with?
And they have the questions that
are most common between it's
like, do you like horror
movies and whatnot.
So when people fill out
what's important to them
and what's not when they're
answering questions,
is there any sort
of offsetting that
goes based off of the
data of the masses?
So you see a lot of
couples are matching
based off this question, so the
question has a higher weighting
even though they might say it's
important or not important?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
Is your question
do we use the kind of
successful couples data
to kind of refactor what's
happening in the algorithm?
AUDIENCE: Exactly, yeah.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: The answer
is no, mostly because,
first of all, that
particular blog post wasn't
based on what was important.
It was based on the
kind of unexpected--
I ranked the questions that were
easy to ask by how high they
correlated with success
in couples, if that makes
any sense.
So the expected
number of couples
that would agree to the horror
movie question, that question
is answered 50/50.
It's like 50.25% of
the site says yes,
and whatever, 49.75 says no.
So the expected
number of couples
that would agree on that
question is about 50%.
However, among all
the successful couples
we've created, at least in
my data set that I know of,
I want to say something
like 72% or 74% of them
agree on that question.
So you can see that
it's a very high number
to agree certainly
at random chance.
But anyway, to get back to
your question, the people who
actually come back and
tell us stuff is just,
it's a small set.
They have to go through
this tree of things
and then indicate and have to
come back after they've already
been dating for months.
It's just very few people
relative to the couples
that we actually create.
And it's highly self-selected.
They're like OkCupid super
fans, or they're actually
getting married.
And a lot of people
aren't coming
OkCupid to get
married necessarily.
And so we would end up steering
this site in this one direction
and away from all
these other things
that people might
be doing on OkCupid.
So short answer is
we don't use it.
And generally we're kind
of deprecating the weight
that people give questions.
We've found that people, it
really is mood dependent.
Whereas your answer isn't, but
how important it is to you is.
So there's many
different questions
that ask basically about
flag burning, for example.
And people know what they
think about flag burning,
whether it's November
or August or they're
in a good mood or what.
You answer the question,
but how important
it is to you at
that moment, we've
seen basically there can be
a battery of questions that
are exactly the same, and
people's importance levels
are all over the place.
So we're thinking about
bringing that out.
We've already reduced
one of the things.
Maybe it was just
because there was
too many options and people
were just clicking randomly.
But we might move to a more of
a deal breakers type of thing,
which again is like
a yes/no thing.
It's not a how do
I feel about this.
It's like, is this
going to keep me
from ever wanting to
see somebody who smokes,
or if you're a
vegetarian who eats meat,
or who believes in God
if you're an atheist.
These are things
that people already
know a little bit better
than how important is it
to you that somebody takes a
shower twice a day or whatever.
It's just like,
pfft, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Got you.
And just one other quick thing.
What happens when
you skip rating?
So you have one to five
and then there's the skip.
What happens when people
skip, like if you see--
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
Oh, on Quickmatch?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Nothing.
It just moves on.
And the skip rates are
pretty independent.
People just get skipped.
It's a pretty noisy indicator.
You could treat it
as a zero, but it
doesn't seem like
that is how it works.
It's like another one
of these mood things.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I just wanted
to thank you guys for OkCupid
because I met my
wife through OkCupid.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Awesome,
great, I like the stereo,
I'm just going to
sit over there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I know, exactly.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: That's key.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no,
that's my comment.
Thank you.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
Oh, thanks man.
That's great.
All right.
AUDIENCE: What was most
surprising in two senses?
What did you learn that
was most surprising to you,
and what have you learned
that when you tell people
they're like, oh, I had no idea
about myself or about people?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
OK, so I'll answer.
I'm very wordy, so the
two sentences maybe I'll
just use a lot of semicolons.
The most surprising
thing to me was
when I looked at the racial
data, as an American,
I expected a certain
amount of bias.
But the depth of it and
the cookie-cutter nature,
if you think of it
as a matrix, it just
seemed like you could pull the
same matrix from different data
sets-- OkCupid, DateHookup,
which is another site we run,
or match.com, and they're
all just as if they
had been stamped
by the same thing.
The percentage is different a
little bit, but who likes who
and who doesn't like
who on a racial basis
is the same across
these data sets.
Totally different user
acquisition strategies,
totally different
user interfaces,
totally different user bases.
And then through
time on OkCupid,
it's again the same pattern.
And so that sort of pervasive
and persistence of the pattern
I found very surprising.
So that's the answer to that.
I think that people seem
to also be surprised
about that because there
is this kind of-- I mean,
there is a taboo around race.
And if you ask anybody
if they're racist,
obviously no one is going
to say yes to that question.
Does race matter
romantically to you?
Very few people would
say yes to that question.
So that, in my experience,
is what's most surprising.
But again, it's like,
you read the paper.
You grow up in
the United States.
I'm from Little Rock, Arkansas.
Racism shouldn't be
a surprise for sure.
And I think the more you talk to
people who work with big data--
I'm sure you guys see
this all the time-- it
often just confirms your
cynical intuition about people.
But it does add a certain amount
of clarity and specificity,
which can be refreshing
or surprising.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: I don't
know if that was two sentences
or not.
It's just a lot of--
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was curious.
Some of those questions
you asked earlier
that you ask as part of the
profile make a lot of sense.
But how do you come up with
flag burning questions?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: How do I come
up with-- oh, flag burning.
AUDIENCE: Flag burning, how
do you pick up the questions
that you put into the profiles?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Yeah,
the question situation
is a real post-apocalypse free
for all type deal over there.
It's an anything
goes environment.
So, the way the
question starts--
so when you launch a site that's
going to based on questions,
you can't just be
like, OK, here you go,
and there's no question.
So we wrote 50 or something
like that on our own.
So one of the flag burning ones
might be ours that we wrote
back in 2004, '03.
But we opened it up
so people-- again,
we wanted people to be able
to find what they wanted.
So if you really cared
about your significant other
having a foot fetish, you
can get that in there.
And it is in there.
And so people wrote
questions and submitted them.
And I think people have
submitted something
like 260,000.
We turned it off because
they became so redundant.
And there's only maybe 5,000
that are in circulation.
But the way we prioritize the
questions, again, is automated.
So the ranking heuristic
is, how much information
does each question yield?
And that is-- again,
to break that out--
is how important is
the question generally?
And of course, as
I was just saying,
importance is a
little bit of a thing.
But I think back
then especially it
seemed like people
would answer correctly.
So how important on average
is a question, and then
the next important step is
how divisive is the question?
And what I mean by that is
how much does it segment
the user base 50/50,
the closer the better.
Because a question
like have you ever
murdered somebody is extremely
important to know the answer,
but everybody
answers the same way,
so you get no real
information from them.
So under this algorithm,
the best questions
bubbled up to the top.
But a flaw in this
that we realized
is that these similar questions,
because they're similar,
bubbled up to roughly
the same spot.
And so you end up having
somebody coming to your site
and having to answer a whole
battery of questions about flag
burning that they're
like, what the hell
is going on on this dating site?
And so we went in and did
some editorial, essentially,
and kind of cherry picked
the ones that were best.
And now it's hard coded.
The first, say, 100, 150
I think, we didn't write,
but we decided where they would
go because they flowed better
together.
You didn't have a bunch of
religion questions clumped
together and stuff like that.
So yeah, the questions is way
more curated than it started.
And it'll probably stay kind
of like it is regardless
of what people
submit in the future.
AUDIENCE: And how many questions
do people answer on average?
Because that takes a long time.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
Yeah, I know, I know.
I don't know the median.
There's obviously a
long tail problem here,
but the average is maybe
like 330 or something.
My guess would be the
median's around 200.
So a lot, because
people, they'll browse.
They've seen some
people, and then
they just get bored
and just start
powering through this thing.
But for the site to work,
we only need 10, 15.
I mean, it could work
without it if you just
care about pictures.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just wondering if
you-- sorry, this is--
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: It's OK.
I can hear you.
AUDIENCE: Wondering if you
saw any interesting change
in behavior or trends once
Tinder became more mainstream.
Did it have an impact on--
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Sure,
that's a great question.
Yeah, I mean, again,
longitudinal or cohort
data is really hard for us
because people just, they come.
They hate it, or they find
someone they love, or whatever,
and they go.
And we don't know why.
But honestly, this has been
the best year over year
that we've had
since year over year
meant building from
almost nothing.
So this has been the
best year we've ever
had by almost any metric.
So I think there's a
lot of people on OkCupid
who also use Tinder.
I don't think it's a winner
take all type situation.
People want dates.
I don't think they
necessarily care
via which app it comes to them.
And I think more
than anything, Tinder
has destroyed that last
brick in the stigma wall
around online dating.
I think their user
base is way younger,
people who, at least as
far as I understand it,
might not have
ever tried meeting
someone through their phone.
And they're obviously
doing in droves.
And it's kind of
conditioning people to-- it's
the end of people
thinking meeting someone
through a phone is
weird, or a computer.
But I think that's
not to say that Tinder
doesn't present challenges.
I think in becoming popular and
playing the role that they've
played in breaking down the
stigma for an entire segment
of the world that we
never had access to,
we now need to be
able to address
the expectations of those people
better than having profiles
and this heavy stuff.
Tinder is so light, and so
when someone likes Tinder
and they're like, I wonder
what else is out there,
we need to make sure that
when they download OkCupid
because they heard
it was cool it
fits their expectations
of what it's going to be.
And I think that's something
that we're working on.
Well, I know that's
something we're working on.
I think that's
something we'll figure.
AUDIENCE: Right.
What about the stigma
that Tinder in itself
has with the more
casual behavior.
Are you seeing-- that might
be overall mainstream behavior
trends anyway, but--
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: You
know, honestly, I'm
not up to the latest on
what's happening at Tinder,
totally honest.
I don't know what
to think about it.
I think it's a
phenomenal experience.
I remember when
people-- or UX, when
people, November
of 2012, Sam, one
of my co-founders
at OkCupid was like,
hey, what do you think of this?
And he came in.
I was like, shit.
This is cool.
And it's self-evidently
cool and fun,
which is an amazing
thing for an app.
And there's a lot of
people that aren't
looking for long-term
relationships.
They're not looking
to get married.
You're 24.
I mean, I remember I
moved here when I was 25,
and that's the last thing
that was on my mind.
So I don't think it's
necessarily a problem at all.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Have you
had any example
of change in the user
interface depending
on the location of the person?
Like someone from
Europe would expect
to get married maybe
in the 30s, maybe
someone in the US earlier.
Have you had any example
where you've seen impact
by changing the user interface
on the amount of users
that you get?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
Like one UX might--
we make a UX change
site-wide, and we
see that it gains more
traction in Germany
than it does here, for example.
The answer is no,
mostly because I
feel like that's
such a noisy thing.
Again, it's new
people coming in.
And it could just be some
other Zeitgeist issue,
or maybe Tinder just became
super popular in Germany and so
people are looking
for the next step.
If we spend a lot of time
researching that question,
I might believe
what came out of it.
But once you're saying
that, then you probably
don't ever bother
to look into it.
Do you know what I'm saying?
AUDIENCE: What
about the questions?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: What?
AUDIENCE: What
about the questions?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
The questions--
OkCupid is by far more
popular in the United States
and then even
outside that in Anglo
countries, the British
Commonwealth essentially.
And I think a big
limiting factor
for us has been that
there's so much vernacular.
It's so English.
We have a voice in
a way that, say,
Tinder does not because it's
just pictures and an interface.
And so that I think
has been a problem.
And we tried to
internationalize way
too soon, like 2007 or 2008.
It was this enormous translator
project, and it was just, pfft.
So we're going to try again.
But it's insightful to realize
that it doesn't transport
as well, because it
doesn't, unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: And one more question.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When you internalize,
when you go to another country,
do you go in favor
of hiring people
from that country to understand
their culture better?
[INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: When
we do, yes, we will hire.
I think if we decide to say
go into Spain-- of course
OkCupid is available
in Spain, so it's
a little bit of a
misrepresentation
of what would happen.
But when we decide to
try to make OkCupid more
popular in Spain,
we will definitely
hire someone who is
either a Spaniard
or has spent a lot of time there
and understands the culture.
Because dating,
unlike, say, search,
I imagine people searching for
things in Europe or in the US
are kind of doing
the same thing.
I guess there might be
grammatical differences in how
the thing gets laid out.
But there is actual cultures,
different dating cultures
that you have to address
that are very difficult.
In Germany, for
example, they kind of
reject-- even though most people
certainly can read English,
they just want it to be
German and feel very Deutsche.
But in the Netherlands,
they don't care.
And in China, for
example, IAC owns
part of a dating site
in China and is actually
a call center with a website
that you find people,
and then you call in.
It's like 3,000 people that
someone will take your call
and help you.
It's a totally
different deal where
they have to maintain this older
school village matchmaker vibe.
So it's a weird problem
to have to address.
But anyway, thanks.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: So, all the popular
dating sites to my mind
had radically different
visions of how
this system was
supposed to work.
OkCupid had this
dynamic question,
automatic ranking system.
And it seems like there
were all very distinctive,
and I wonder if you
feel like there's
a phenomenon of
convergence to the mean
or discovery of an underlying
platonic dating site
that everybody--
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: I don't know
if mean is the right word,
but I think there probably
is some convergence.
Like in any industry, there's
going to be best practices.
And for instance, for
ways to vote on people,
the swipe gesture that Tinder
came up with is awesome.
It would be stupid
to have a button that
says no and says
yes at this point.
You've got to make
it swipe, right?
Certainly I think
the business model
differences will stay the same.
That's part of the way
people's-- to someone
else's question earlier, the
fact that Match asked people
to pay, I think there's a lot
of people, perhaps justifiably,
consider that a
marker of seriousness.
If you have paid to
be there, then they
know that you're
not dicking around.
You're not going to troll
them or whatever it is.
And some people want
that assurance for sure.
I think that will stay.
We'll probably also change
subtly in some ways,
and there will be
probably more convergence
as we've started charging
for some things too.
In terms of the
UX, I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know.
Dating is the weirdest thing.
It's one of the few
things that people
will pay for on the internet.
And so people are always
trying to horn in on it.
And it's very PR related.
You see there's dating sites
out there that are essentially
a press release
and nothing more.
Like Cupidtino, the
dating site for Mac users,
it still shows up
in articles about
the online dating landscape.
And I guarantee you no
one is on that site.
For real.
I mean, there was an article
about IAC's dating portfolio
a week, two weeks
ago in the "Times."
It's kind of very serious
treatment of what we're doing
and what might happen.
And in there, they list
as a possible threat
to the portfolio a
couple legit sites.
And then just with no other
commentary, seacaptaindate.com,
which is a site
for-- you should all
go check it out-- for sea
captains to find dates.
And so you're just like, what?
This is not a site, you guys.
So where this is
going to is I think
there will be consolidation
and then fragmentation,
like the way a forest
works after a fire.
You know what I mean?
There's always going to be new
and regenerative sites like Sea
Captain Date.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Hey.
AUDIENCE: You recently had an
article in the "Wall Street
Journal" on some
of the experiments
that were being conducted.
My wife and I were
wondering what
the nature of those
experiments were
and whether they were
being run specifically
in January of 2010.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Well, I
mean, you guys certainly
must know that websites
are always testing things.
Certainly when it comes to
a recommendation algorithm,
whether it's recommending
some news from your friend
you want to hear on your
Facebook wall or news feed,
or some search result that is
pertinent to the kidney beans
that you just searched for, or
whatever you've searched for,
or who we think you
might want to talk to.
So I guarantee you
there something
in flux generally then.
That particular
experiment was not,
and anybody who communicated
as part of that experiment
was notified
immediately afterwards.
That experiment
occurred basically right
before I wrote about it.
And the experiment was a tweak
to our matching algorithm,
as you would call it.
But we basically ran
it against placebo,
which had the effect of testing
it against-- you think of all
the real-world ways
that people match
or real-world ideas for
putting people together.
There's birds of
a feather, which
is things in common, which
is how we generally work.
There's the you're my type and
she's your type type of thing,
the way match.com does it.
There's opposites attract,
which is essentially
what got tested
in the experiment
that you're talking about.
There's also she's
from a good family.
You're from a good family.
You're done, kind of
old-world way to do things.
And then there's
many different ways.
We're always testing and
seeing which one is better.
So that's kind of what
that was all about.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hey again.
A question for you.
Since you guys were kind of
trailblazers in destigmatizing
online dating, was
there any hilarious
stories from the
founding, the startup,
talking to your parents.
Hey, I'm doing an online
dating site for a living?
What was something
funny that happened?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Something
funny that happened.
AUDIENCE: That's a
very vague question.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: No, no,
no, no, it's a good question.
I mean, you know, certainly
part of OkCupid's voice
is kind of humorous, and
the book is humorous,
and I like to tell jokes.
But I'm also a very
grim, focused person,
just like the other guys
who work at OkCupid.
And so we're just
like [GROWL] sitting
in there trying to make the
site popular when it's not.
Man, I mean, there's a
ton of nonsense, I guess,
which I mostly just
remember as a big,
it's like a primordial
ooze of silliness.
I don't know.
Mostly in terms of
startup-related stories,
the things that stick in my mind
are kind of all the missteps.
I remember sitting in the office
when someone was like, hey
dude, have you heard of
this thing Friendster?
And we were like, shit.
By the way, just like I remember
sitting in SparkNotes office
when someone was like, hey,
have you heard of Google?
And we're like, oh, yeah.
I guess I don't need to
use AltaVista anymore,
which is what I used to use for
real for all my image searches
especially.
It was better than
anything at the time.
So when Friendster came
out, we were like, oh, cool.
That's awesome.
We should add
friends to OkCupid.
So we had the basic friend
technology, and nobody used it.
We've tried a blind date app.
Nobody uses it.
It's like one of these
things that there's always
an imperative for a site to grow
and innovate and add things.
And Google especially has done
this incredibly well, Search
and then Maps and Gmail
and all this stuff.
But for a dating
site, people's need
for sex or love, that
doesn't really change.
And it's very hard
to add things.
It's also very focused.
It's very hard to add
extra things onto it.
So I know that's not
what you're asking.
I mean--
AUDIENCE: I mean, what are your
thoughts on farmersonly.com?
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: We are
quaking in our mud-covered boots
on that one for sure.
I mean, I guess, yeah, we
had this one-- well, no.
I'm not going to say it
because it's too personal.
There's some funny
personnel stories,
but obviously that
involves other people
that I don't want to
talk about, so yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'll ask later.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
The class of people
who will work for a startup
with very dubious prospects
and no money is a strange group
of people, I'll tell you that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER:
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So, I haven't
checked on the gender options
on okcupid.com in a while.
Maybe you've changed
it, but I think
last time I looked,
it was just, I
am a man/woman
interested in men/women.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to include non-binary gender
options?
Or are their difficulties
in supporting that?
I can imagine there
might be, but--
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: There are.
And the answer to both
your questions is yes.
That's in progress, and maybe
we're about to launch a test.
When Facebook came out
with the 51 or 57 options
like they did on
Valentine's Day,
that's kind of throwing down
the gauntlet a little bit.
And it's a question that
many people internally
are highly interested in
supporting that functionality.
But we built the site how
we built it back in 2003,
and it's kind of like
[EXPLOSION SOUND]
into the code, the binary.
And it's also not
as easy as simply
displaying what someone is.
You have this discovery
problem, which is at least half
of the experience.
And so there's so
many types of tools
that we could roll out
that would give people
more fine-grained control,
and this is one of them.
But people can very
easily blow themselves up
by selecting-- if you're
two-spirited or something, one
of the ones that's
on Facebook's list,
you have every right
to have that identity.
And then you also
have every right
to expect people to
be able to find you.
And if you put
yourself in as a gender
that there's not very
many people actively
searching specifically
for that, you
can describe yourself
in a way, and then
you basically end
up in a black hole.
Because no one will
find you, even people
you would be open to
talking to or dating.
And so the discovery
problem, and that's
a very specific
example, but the problem
exists for almost every one
of the ones on that list
is that people have specific
ideas about who they are
but not necessarily specific
descriptive ideas about who
they want to date, generally.
And so you kind of
have this asymmetry
in what people are
willing to search for
and how people are willing
to describe themselves.
Does that make sense to you?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
CHRISTIAN RUDDER: OK, so
it's a hard thing to solve,
and we're working on it.
But also our back end kind
of gives us trouble, frankly.
Oh, OK, cool.
All right guys.
Well, thanks for having me.
And I hope you buy the book.
It's funny and good.
And for those of you that use
OkCupid, thank you very much.
And thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]